[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs durch die arktis kaum
jemand hat sie je so gysi
es ist eine reise die uns oft alles
abverlangt durch eine raue wilde welt
die kein erbarmen kennt und doch so
voller zauber steckt
[Musik]
wir wollen verstehen wie sich diese welt
ändert und was das für uns alle bedeutet
wir treffen menschen die ihr glück kaum
fassen können und die ihre zukunft
wenige phasen
[Musik]
schon immer war die arktis mehr als nur
ein ort der sehnsucht nach
ursprünglicher schönheit jahrtausende
galt sie als unbezwingbar heute aber ist
ein wettlauf ausgebrochen darum wer sie
in zukunft dominiert
[Musik]
einmal um den erdball sind wir geflogen
durch den hohen norden um aufzuspüren
was auch uns alle zukommen in einer welt
die sich verändert
[Musik]
wir sind im anflug auf die aleuten ein
oft sturmumtosten vulkanischen insel
kette die sich vom festland alaskas weit
hinein in den nordpazifik gestreckt die
rauen inseln überzogen mit einem sanften
grün unsere reise durch die arktis
beginnt hier weit südlich des
polarkreises
überall auf der insel relikte aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg
schiff racks und bunker wir sind hier
auf eine geschichte gestoßen die klar
macht dass am horizont wieder ein neuer
gefährlicher konflikt aufzieht hoch oben
im norden in der arktis
jetzt ende juli aber bei
höchsttemperaturen von um die 11 grad
zeigen sich der aleuten von ihrer
sanften ihrer gutmütigen seite
[Musik]
das aber auf der hauptinsel in alaska
ist er vom volumen her umsatzstärkste
fischereihafen der usa es ist ein
milliardengeschäft
wo 350.000 tonnen fisch und
meeresfrüchte seelachs kabeljau heilbutt
und die großen kink raps werden hier
jedes jahr gelöscht und in die ganze
welt verschickt
die reste holen sich die adler diese
gibt wie tauben in berlin oder venedig
1741 wurden die rund 160 inseln von
vitus bering entdeckt bei dem dänischen
offizier der im auftrag des russischen
zaren herausfinden sollte ob es eine
landverbindung gibt zwischen dem
amerikanischen kontinent und russland
eine kleine russisch orthodoxe kirche
erinnert noch an die zeit bevor russland
die inseln zusammen mit alaska
1867 für 7,2 millionen dollar an die usa
verkauft hat ein gutes geschäft für
amerika ein geschäft dass russland
bereit bis heute
von dacia brechen die verbote zu den
fischgründen im hohen norden in der
beringsee auf mehr als 1000 kilometer
entfernt an einem der unwirtlichsten
orte der welt
es ist etwa 4 uhr morgens als die blue
dolphins dutch harbor 1 läuft es ist ein
schiff das weit in den norden vordringen
kann
drei monate waren sie in der beringsee
nahe der russischen grenze unterwegs die
blue note ist das modernste schiff der
amerikanischen fangflotte mit platz für
mehr als 600 tonnen fisch wir haben uns
mit captain david anderson verabredet
sei der 19 ist fährt er als fischer zu
sehr auf in den norden erst als
einfacher matrose heute als kapitän
schon seit monaten sind wir mit ihm via
satellit in kontakt er hat uns videos
geschickt die zeigen was es bedeutet in
der beringsee zu fischen und uns wird
schon vom zuschauen schlecht
[Musik]
herten anderson will uns von einem
gefährlichen aufeinandertreffen erzählen
einer möglichen neuen frontlinie der aus
seiner sicht viel zu wenig
aufmerksamkeit geschenkt wird
der erste gedanke war ich muss diesen
typen jetzt zu hören die sind zu allem
fähig die sind unberechenbar ich musste
meine crew schützen
und er will uns zeigen was er erlebt hat
auf dem weg gibt uns eine tour durch das
schiff auf dass er sehr stolz ist
herzstück ist der sogenannte mond pool
ein großes loch im rumpf dass die leine
noch bei sturm eingeholt werden können
ohne die crew dem wetter auszusetzen
die du nord ist ein sogenannter longline
insgesamt 70 kilometer sind die leiden
lang
wir haben 55 magazin an ein magazin hat
1200 tag
x 55 dann sind das um die 65.000 tagen
die wir an bord haben
wir rund um die uhr fischen
es ist eine schwimmende
hochleistungsmaschine ein schlachtschiff
wenn man so will fast alles ist
automatisiert
die fische der kabeljau vor allem werden
ausgenommen und gesäubert nach größe und
gewicht sortiert verpackt und
schließlich noch an bord tiefgefroren
es ist ein riesengeschäft mehr als drei
millionen dollar bringt jede ladung
verkauft werden die ganze welt doch der
aufwand wird von jahr zu jahr größer es
wird immer schwerer an die fische
ranzukommen
die fische waren dann definitiv daran
gibt es keinen zweifel
und es gibt nur eine richtung für sie
nämlich nach norden als das wasser
kälter also schwimmen sie dorthin und
wir fischer müssen dahin wo der fisch
ist also folgen wir ihnen
vor zehn jahren sind wir 18 stunden
gefahren bis wir etwas gefangen haben
jetzt sind es zweieinhalb tage
da sieht man wie stark sich alles
verändert
je weiter die fische aber in den norden
richtung arktis wandern umso enger wird
es zwischen den küsten russlands und
amerikas auf der brücke erzählt uns
captain anderson dann die geschichte
wegen der wir uns mit ihm treffen
wollten er hat den ganzen vorfall mit
seiner handykamera aufgenommen
das flugzeug kam von dort drüben man
sieht dass auf dem video ich stand
ungefähr hier und habe gefilmt aus der
distanz nähert sich ein flugzeug
erst habe ich gedacht das wäre die
küstenwache kein problem das kennen wir
aber dann wurde mir klar es ist militär
da habe ich gedacht jetzt ist es ernst
hier stimmt irgendwas nicht
vor allem als mir dann klar wurde dass
es nicht unser militär war
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit deutlich russischem akzent die
flugzeugbesatzung den fischern
abzudrehen immer wieder die ansage über
funk sie sollten kurs 135 nehmen mit
maximaler geschwindigkeit
das brisante an der situation es sind
russen die das amerikanische fischerboot
auffordern zu verschwinden aus
amerikanischen gewässern mit auf der
brücke war auch michael jarrell der
zweite kapitän der blues
stand wirklich spitze auf knopf
sie sagten wir sollen abhauen sie sind
uns richtig auf die pelle gerückt
das ist so als würde man mit panzern und
lastwagen über die us grenze kommen und
zivilisten auffordern zu verschwinden
wir haben in unseren gewässern gefischt
und dann ist genau das passiert
bis heute ist nicht geklärt warum das
russische militär so aggressiv
vorgegangen ist
im hafen treffen wir die crew des award
kleiner kutter aus holz vier mann
besatzung es herrscht konzentrierte
angespannte geschäftigkeit
die crew bereitet sich vor auszulaufen
zu ihren fanggründen 800 kilometer
nördlich in der beringsee
nach ein paar bier und whiskey hatte uns
captain garrett gründers und am vorabend
eingeladen ein stück mitzufahren zum
tanken und zum lebensmittel bunkern
einmal um die insel
gut für die stimmung an bord sei dass da
habe die crew in den nächsten tagen
etwas worüber sie reden könnte denn die
würden anstrengt
vier meter wählen werden wir auf dem weg
hoch haben aber sie kommen von hinten
wir werden also den ganzen weg werfen
wenn wir ankommen werden wir unsere
leinen auslegen für etwa drei tages dann
wird das kräftig blasen um die 40 meilen
pro stunde wir werden uns dann in
sicherheit bringen und hinter einer
insel ankern und abfahren
an deck sichert die crew die fan
ausrüstung wellen oft höher als zehn
meter sind in der beringsee keine
seltenheit sturm und wellen aber sind
die fischer gewohnt mehr sorgen bereitet
der crew etwas anderes
vor ungefähr 25 jahren und du musst ihn
nur ein oder zwei mal begegnen dann
wissen sie was du tust
sie warten darauf dass du fischer ein
wust und dann schnappen sie sich die
fische von
uns auf jagen und fischen
wenn die killer falle auftauchen das
game over dann fängst du nichts mehr ich
über jahre haben wir an der kante der
kontinentalplatte gefischt aber als die
killerwale darauf tauchten mussten sie
quasi fliegen immer weiter nach norden
das wasser ist kälter da und aus welchem
grund auch immer so weit nach norden
gehen
aber irgendwann ist auch für die sun
lodge schluss der weg nach norden ist
für sie nicht unendlich
wir haben nur eine begrenzte reichweite
mit diesem
weiter nördlich als zu in sulz
interviews kommen wir nicht wenn sie
noch genügend sprit und wasser haben
wollen um auch wieder zurückzukommen
nachdem
das boot ist einfach nicht groß genug
ob sie auch schon mal beim fischen
vertrieben wurden sie davon gehört
hätten was der blue nord und anderen
fischerbooten passiert sei fragen wir
den kapitän
wir haben letztes jahr davon gehört wir
selber haben die aber nie gesehen wir
waren richtung westen unterwegs als wir
über funk die nachricht bekamen
russische kriegsschiffe würden unsere
jungs nicht fischen lassen was er als
kapitän denn machen würde wenn die
russen ihn aus seinen fanggründen
vertreiben würden wollen wir von ihm
noch wissen
von den russen ich wäre vollkommen vom
militär was soll ich da machen
natürlich ich habe keine kanonen an bord
soll ich die mit fischen
zurück auf der blumenhof die beiden
kapitäne david anderson und mike gerhold
erwarten nach ihrer begegnung mit dem
russischen militär im hohen norden jetzt
dass die amerikanische regierung handelt
auch weil sich die arktis verändert
die fische ziehen immer weiter in den
norden und mit ihnen die fischerboot ich
denke unser militär sollte auch weiter
in den norden ziehen
ich denke es wäre eine vernünftige
entscheidung für das us militär und für
uns alle
ganz ehrlich es wäre besonders gut für
uns fischer denn wer weiß was die
zukunft in der arktis bringt
weil die fische immer weiter in den
norden ziehen richtung arktis setzen die
fischer auf militärische unterstützung
und uns schwant dass unsere reise durch
die arktis für uns noch viele
überraschungen bergen wird
wir verlassen die aleuten für uns geht
es richtung osten nach pond inlet in der
kanadischen arktis am eingang der
nordwestpassage
kanada ist schon dabei sich auf die
neuen konflikte vorzubereiten baffin
island ist die fünftgrößte insel der
welt eineinhalb mal so groß wie
deutschland und nahezu unbewohnt
der eisbrecher harrieder wurf der
königlich kanadischen marine ist auf
patrouillenfahrt oft tagelang durch
unbesiedelte gebiete durch eine welt die
sich mehr und mehr von weiß-blau
verwandelt
[Musik]
captain fließen und seine crew sind
dabei den meeresboden zu vermessen
wassertiefe und geologische strukturen
denn wir hier in der abgeschiedenheit
des arktischen nordens operieren will
muss eine genaue vorstellung davon haben
wie es über und unter wasser aussieht
laut karte hätten wir uns gerade eben in
einer wassertiefe von 50 metern befinden
sollen aber in wirklichkeit waren es 80
meter das ist zu ungenau so kann man ein
schiff dieser größe nicht sicher
navigieren das reicht vielleicht für ein
segelboot aber nicht für einschiffen
dieses
an deck bereitet sich die crew auf etwas
vor was kanada hier oben noch nie
gemacht hat noch ist es ein test aber
schon bald soll es standard werden bei
den patrouillen durch die
nordwestpassage in
etwa fünf minuten bremsen wir ab und
dann kann's losgehen
als das schiff abbremst lassen ließen es
leute ein dickes kabel ins wasser an dem
kabel ist eine art schlitten befestigt
ein hochmodernes so nah gerät dass sie
durch diese abgelegenen arktischen
gewässer ziehen
wir haben gerade unsere erste
unterwasser aufklärungs patrouille
durchgeführt um so ein besseres bild von
den arktischen gewässern zu bekommen und
zu verstehen was unter wasser passiert
die u-boote und andere schiffe im norden
operieren die unsere souveränität hier
entweder unterstützen oder untergraben
wollen
kanada will demonstrieren dass es in der
lage ist sein anspruch in der arktis
nicht nur zu erheben sondern auch
durchzusetzen
mit an bord der herr riedel wurf eine
truppe fallschirmjäger aus dem süden
kanadas letzte vorbereitungen bevor es
an land geht die soldaten sollen ein
gefühl dafür bekommen die groß und
einsam das land ist dass im ernstfall
verteidigen müssen
wir schicken euch jetzt alle an land er
möchte position beziehen zieht euch warm
an hier bleibt er mindestens 45 stunden
sorgt dafür dass ihr genügend zu essen
und zu trinken haben wir verbrennt er
eine ganze menge kalorien und passt gut
aufeinander auf
nachfragen
die rechnung ist gut
[Musik]
nur sehr wenige kanadier kennen ihr
eigenes land hier im norden so weit weg
und zu schwer zu erreichen noch immer
und man spürt den soldaten an das ist
auch für sie ein großes abenteuer ist
haben nördlichen ende der welt unterwegs
zu sein am eigenen leib die wilde
ursprünglichkeit dieser mächtigen natur
zu erleben
mit den arctic ranger lokalen inuit
einheiten die den ganzen norden kanadas
patroullieren von der west- bis an die
ostküste trainieren sie die
zusammenarbeit es ist ein lernen von und
miteinander
[Applaus]
die ranger bringen den soldaten bei wie
man in dieser rauen welt in der man oft
auf sich allein gestellt ist überlebt
sekunde schießen und zerlegen gehört
dabei zu den wichtigsten
überlebensstrategien den see und fleisch
enthält viel vitamin c sagen sie wichtig
in einer gegend in der es weder bäume
noch obst und gemüse gibt
besonders nahrhaft ist die leber
die konsistenz ist ein bisschen
bghs see und fleisch aber habe neben den
vitaminen die es enthält noch einen
anderen vorteil hier oben im winter ganz
besonders wichtig sei
wenn dir kalt ist im winter dann ist ein
bisschen von der leber und dann wird er
in 15 minuten war wirklich das ist eine
chemische reaktion in deinem körper der
mit dem see und blut reagiert da
passiert was du musst gar nicht viel
essen
die akte granger sind die augen und
ohren im norden lokale fischer und jäger
die praktisch das ganze jahr über die
arktis durchstreifen um ihre familien zu
versorgen und sie erklären den soldaten
wie man hier überlebt
ja gut machst du das
die soldaten umgekehrt trainieren die
akti granger darin mit funk über weite
strecken zu kommunizieren und sie rüsten
sie mit dem aus was sie dafür brauchen
ihr könnt damit mit dem militärflugzeug
sprechen und mit den schiffen
auch wenn ihr hier search and rescue
macht könnt ihr damit direkt mit den
flugzeugen oder den helikoptern
kommunizieren
auch wenn nicht immer alles auf anhieb
klappt für die kanadischen truppen
werden die akte granger emma wichtig
[Gelächter]
unser job ist es ausschau zu halten was
im norden in unserem territorium los ist
und wenn wir etwas sehen ungewöhnliche
schiffe oder u boote oder andere
aktivitäten dann berichten wir das an
das hauptquartier in yellowknife
das letzte was wir gesehen haben war 300
kilometer nördlich von pons inlet
wir haben das gemeldet und ein foto
gemacht
war dass ein u-boot
woher die schiffe und das u boot kamen
keine aussage dazu aber seit sowjetische
unterwasser karten der nordwestpassage
entdeckt wurden die aus der zeit des
kalten krieges stammen und die sehr viel
genauer waren als die kanadischen geht
man in kanada davon aus dass schon lange
unentdeckter besuch durch kanadische
gewässer navigierte
für die soldaten ist eine sache ganz
klar
militärisch sollten wir hier oben mehr
flagge zeigen wir brauchen eine stärkere
truppenpräsenz um den kanadiern und der
ganzen welt zu zeigen dass wir das heft
in der hand hat das ist kein
niemandsland es gehört uns und wir
wachen darüber
es gibt viel zu viel gerede darum wem
ihr was gehört das ist unser hinter wir
müssen einen zaun darum bauen und dieser
zaun sind wir
in einem atemberaubenden tempo verändert
sich der norden kanadas regierung
versucht schritt zu halten die harry de
wurf ist ihre erste antwort fünf
weiterer solcher robusten
patrouillenbootes in dem bau kann oder
will sie in den nächsten jahren in der
arktis einsetzen
wir fangen gerade erst an hier im norden
routinemäßig zu operieren denn die
situation in der arktis erlaubt uns das
jetzt normalerweise operieren schiffe
nicht so weit im norden zu keiner
jahreszeit aber kann er das arktis ist
dabei sich immer weiter zu öffnen es
kommen immer mehr schiffe immer weiter
in den norden das zwingt kann aber auch
immer mehr schiffe in den norden zu
schicken die königlich kanadische marine
ist ein teil dieses plans
der druck auf die rohstoffreiche und
strategisch wichtige region wird immer
größer kanada will seine souveränität
über die nordwestpassage bewahren will
nicht zum spielball der arktischen
großmächte usa und russland werden aber
auch wenn das eis langsam verschwinden
eines gibt captain ließen allen die sich
hier oben herum treiben wollen mit auf
den weg
unterschätzt die arktis recht man kann
die arktis nicht kontrollieren sie
verändert sich ständig man braucht einen
plan wenn man hierher kommen will aber
es muss einem klar sein dass dieser plan
schon im ersten moment scheitern kann
dann muss man sich anpassen kann
was kapitän gelesen damit meint werden
wir sehr viel später in grönland doch am
eigenen leib erfahren
für uns geht es ab jetzt mit einem
kleinen einmotorigen propellerflugzeug
weiter werden wir von der kräuter
begleitet er ist ein erfahrener pilot
der schon in der antarktis gelandet ist
bevor es losgeht müssen wir üben unsere
überlebens anzüge anzuziehen vier
minuten gibt uns direkt dafür
fast
zwei minuten 30 das ist verdammt gut man
in seinem früheren leben war dirk
erfolgreicher unternehmer und banker
heute bereist er die welt kennt sich aus
mit flugbedingungen an orten an denen es
so schnell keine hilfe gibt wenn etwas
schief geht er gilt als einer der besten
vor uns liegt eine abenteuerliche reise
über die labradorsee grönland und im
nordatlantik viele stunden über
unbewohntes gebiet an die einsamsten
orte dieser welt nur aus der luft oder
mit dem schiff zu erreichen sind
die grönländische westküste taucht vor
uns auf bier geht in den tiefflug die
sicht sei gut
im ersten moment können wir nicht so
recht begreifen was wir da sehen worauf
dir die maschine zusteuert
[Musik]
es ist eine welt die bislang kaum jemand
so gesehen hat
eine welt die uns sofort in ihren bann
zieht wir fliegen über zerklüftete
eislandschaften immer wieder ihre farbe
wechseln
[Musik]
im tiefflug geht es über gletscher und
durch die fjorde und uns verschlägt es
immer wieder den hut
[Musik]
es ist eine welt die uns demütig macht
vor den wundern der natur
[Musik]
sowas ist eine erbarmungslose welt die
fehler nicht verzeiht viele sind hier
oben umgekommen oder abgestürzt bei dem
versuch den mächtigen eispanzer zu
queren selten geht es hier oben so
friedlich und so sanft zu wie heute
[Musik]
den frühen tagen der luftfahrt als der
luftverkehr nach europa noch mit
propellerflugzeugen lief konnten die
maschine nicht mehr als 14.000 fuß
steigen nicht viel höher als das eis da
gab es auch situationen in denen sie im
nebel geflogen sagt und alles ganz gut
aussah bis sie die propeller hörten die
klack klack klack aufs eis trafen und
das flugzeug landete hoffentlich läuft
heute alles gut
stundenlang geht es über ein gebirge
dessen täler sunny kit mit eis gefüllt
sind
die gigantischen gletscher haben sich in
den letzten zwei bis drei millionen
jahren gebildet noch sind 80% grönland
von eis bedeckt
[Musik]
nur an den küsten ist überhaupt leben
möglich wir sind im anflug auf kohle zog
im südosten der insel
unter uns tauchen kleine häuser auf den
bunten farben davon künden dass wir
nicht mehr alleine sind
polus zug ist eine der wenigen siedlung
an der grönländischen ostküste ob wir
200 menschen leben hier von jagd und
fischfang
im letzten jahrhundert quasi über nacht
wird ihre abgeschiedene heimat der die
zeit stillzustehen scheint im reißenden
strom der geschichte mitgerissen geraten
sie in den strudel eines weltpolitischen
klimawandels
im landeanflug geht es für uns über
eisberge und durch karge baumlose fjorde
die uns in ihrer selbstbewussten ruhe
fühlen lassen dass wir menschen nur ein
wimpernschlag der erdgeschichte sind
[Musik]
nach der landung staunen wir nicht
schlecht als die flughafensicherheit
einen großen frontlader vor die maschine
fährt der flughafen chef persönlich
leitete die aktion
ausländische besucher gibt es so gut wie
keine mehr seit ausbruch von corona und
er möchte nicht dass ausgerechnet die
die da kommen die lage unterschätzen
158 kilometer
zwei betonklötze werden noch unter die
flügel gefahren um das flugzeug daran
fest zu binden vor vielen jahren einmal
ein franzose da gewesen mit einer viel
größeren maschine er habe das nicht für
notwendig gehalten
das ergebnis könnten wir uns am ende der
landebahn ansehen
im tower fragen wir nach worauf wir denn
sonst noch so achten müssten
neben den computern des fluglotsen ein
gewehr was ist denn damit auf sich hätte
wollen wir von hans wissen
manchmal müssen wir zur fuß raus gehen
und dann müssen wir vorsichtig sein
wegen der eisbären
hast du schon mal eingetroffen ja
auf eisbären aber werden wir erst sehr
viel später treffen
wir sind verabredet mit rasmus pausen
rasmus ist hauptberuflich kapitän des
polizeibootes der gemeinde er wird uns
etwas zeigen dass uns klar macht dass
die akte ist auch an den abgelegensten
orten schon lange nicht mehr das weiße
kalte wunderland am nördlichen ende der
welt ist das in unseren köpfen herum
zwei stunden bootsfahrt liegen vor uns
volle kraft voraus immer tiefer hinein
in eine welt die so rein und
ursprünglich wirkt und es doch nicht ist
wir landen an einem pier an glasklarem
wasser zwischen giganten aus stein und
schnee
noch können wir nicht sehen was sich
weiter oberhalb verbirgt
erst einmal müssen wir an land gelangen
was ab einem gewissen alter schon eine
recht sportliche aufgabe ist
als das geschafft ist und wir unsere
ausrüstung das ufer hinauftragen
öffnet sich dann der blick auf ein
bizarres stillleben aus rost und stahl
ein stillleben das eine geschichte
erzählt die nur wenige kennen
wir sind auf luiz zu einer
amerikanischen militärbasis aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg oder besser dem was
die us truppen nach ihrem abzug
zurückgelassen haben
dieser stützpunkt wurde in den 40er
jahren während des zweiten weltkrieges
gebaut er ist teil der atlantik-brücke
er für notfälle wenn flugzeuge die von
der südküste kamen probleme hatten
konnten sie hier landen
draußen hinter den bergen im atlantik
tobt damals der unerbittliche u boot
krieg versenkten deutsche u-boote viele
alliierte konvois und flottenverbände
grünen und seine ostküste werden
entscheiden für die schlachten im
atlantik und die bombenangriffe auf
deutschland grönland ist die wetterküche
zwischen europa und amerika der grönland
kontrolliert er weiß was ich hier
zusammenbraut der hat einen
entscheidenden taktischen vorteil
es beginnt ein katz-und-maus-spiel
zwischen amerikanern und deutschen die
versuchen entlang der zerklüfteten
praktisch unbewohnten küste heimlich
wetterstation zu errichten doch alle
versuche der deutschen scheitern nicht
zuletzt weil sie in der wildnis von
lokalen inuit aufgespürt werden
der krieg aber stellt das leben der
inuit zuvor so gut wie keinen kontakt
mit der außenwelt hatten auf den kopf
[Musik]
damals lebten die menschen hier noch wie
in der steinzeit von dem was sie in der
natur finden oder jagen könnten sie
haben treibholz steine und tiere für
alles verwendet was sie brauchten und
dann kamen die amerikaner und die
brachten coca cola lebensmittel in dosen
die menschen gewöhnten sich an diese
neuen dinge und nach dem krieg konnte
man sie ihn ja nicht einfach wieder
wegnehmen
louis ist wirkt auf den ersten blick wie
eine monumentale umweltsünde in dieser
reinen sonst völlig unberührten natur
doch für die menschen die hier leben ist
sie ein segen an einem ort an dem nichts
wächst an dem man auch vorbeidriften des
treibholz aus sibirien angewiesen ist
auch hier zeigt ich denke die leute
haben sich alles mögliche von hier
geholt es gibt ganze häuser in den
umliegenden siedlungen die von hier
stammt die leute sind hierher gekommen
haben die häuser zerlegt und sie im ort
wieder aufgebaut die ganzen ölfässer die
hier liegen einige davon waren noch voll
also haben sich die leute das benzin
geholt in den autos fehlen die motoren
was ist damit passiert
sie wurden wahrscheinlich im ort als
generatoren verwendet als bootsmotoren
usw
die leute haben sich alles von hier
genommen was sie halt irgendwie
gebrauchen konnten seien es jetzt
scheinwerfer lenkräder oder was auch
immer
immer wieder gab und gibt es
diskussionen das was von louis ist noch
übrig ist abzuholen die spuren des
krieges hier in der arktis zu entsorgen
rasmus pausen und viele hier sind
dagegen louis to sein faszinierendes
freilichtmuseum und eine mahnung denkt
ich denke es ist ein sehr interessanter
platz um herzukommen einerseits erzählt
er uns grünen ländern von unserer
geschichte und zum anderen man kann hier
sehen welchen einfluss der mensch haben
kann was er zurücklässt das bleibt die
natur vor allem die natur hier in der
arktis braucht zeit um sich orte wie
diesen zurückzuholen
mit ende des zweiten weltkriegs
verlassen die us-truppen den fjord einer
der einsamsten küsten der welt doch die
konflikte kehren in den norden zurück
scheinen auf an orten die für die
meisten menschen noch immer unerreichbar
sind
wir müssen zurück bevor es dunkel wird
wollen am nächsten morgen weiter hinauf
in den norden es wird eine nacht voller
zauber
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen der trecker kommt mit
dem tankwagen wir wollen weiter nach ida
corr tomi der wahrscheinlich
abgelegensten siedlung der welt
es wird ein langer kalter flug direkt
mit dem benzin noch etwas bei
das ist ein zusatz der dafür sorgt dass
das benzin nicht einfriert
damit der motor nicht auswählt
ja wir ganz gut wenn der motor nicht
ausfallen würden besonders hier und weil
wir nur ein haben
die maschine vollgetankt und quittiert
dann noch mal in den tower zur
verabschiedung und letzte besprechung
über die flugroute knapp 1000 kilometer
liegen vor uns auf einer strecke die
bislang nur sehr wenige geflogen sind
das ist alles um überwachter luftraum
bis nach constable point wenn ihr tiefer
als 6000 meter fliegt worauf müssen wir
den achten wenn wir hoch in den norden
fliegen
wir haben den höchsten berg grönlands
zwischen constable point und colossus
liegt ungefähr da er heißt konzerns er
ist fast 4000 meter
4000 meter
richtig ja irgendwo in dieser gegend bin
mir nicht ganz sicher
noch einmal schnell die fenster putzen
aufpassen sollten wir dass wir bei
schlechter sicht nicht zu tief liegen
mit der rettung könnte es in diesem
unwegsamen gelände ein bisschen dauern
wir zwingen uns in das kleine flugzeug
ausrüstung und überlebens anzüge so gut
es geht die kabine gestopft
abflug in eine unbekannte welt
[Musik]
nach dem start geht es entlang der küste
und wir sind einmal mehr fasziniert von
dieser mächtigen grandiosen natur
[Musik]
nach einer halben stunde etwa geht es
wieder über eine zerklüftete
eislandschaft hinauf aufs eis schild zu
den höchsten bergen grönlands
[Musik]
aus dem kilometer dicken eispanzer ragen
die gipfel eines gebirges das unter ihm
begraben ist auch dirk ist begeistert
diese gletscher von nächster nähe zu
sehen aktiven kräften wurde letzter auf
das meer trifft deutsches und weiter
oben wo das alles ganz glatt es sieht
aus wie ein pulver schneeparadies für
skifahrer und
dazwischen die berge sowie die hier wie
ein matterhorn am anderen ich kenne mich
mit geologie nicht gut aus aber es ist
einfach umwerfend schön
diese pyramidenförmigen spitzendesign
streifen durch den schnee und der
kontrast zwischen dem dunkelgrauen
steinen und dem weißen schnee das ist
einfach traumhaft
es ist das gehäuse
doch was aus der luft mit sicherem
abstand traumhaft wirkt ist unten auf
dem boden brutal und erbarmungslos
1930 bei seiner letzten grönert
expedition kamen hier oben auf dem
eisschild der deutsche metereologe
alfred wegener ums leben in der
deutschen forschungseinrichtung die
seinen namen trägt dem
alfred-wegener-institut
setzen sie wegen das abenteuerliche
forschungen der arktis fort
in einer spektakulären expedition lassen
sich die wissenschaftler 2009/10 auf dem
forschungseisbrecher polarstern
festfrieren ein jahr lang driften sie im
packeis um den nordpol herum sie sammeln
klima eis strömungs und wasser daten
wir hatten uns mit dem expeditionsleiter
vor unserer reise in bremerhaven
verabredet wollten eine idee davon
bekommen was uns erwartet
wir hatten früher dort immer über acht
millionen quadratkilometer eis aus der
arktis liegen heutzutage während des
sommers unserer expedition waren es
unter vier millionen quadratkilometer
die dicke des eises hat sich auch
halbiert wenn diese entwicklung so
weiter geht dann wird in wenigen
jahrzehnten die arktis im sommer eisfrei
werden
das verschwinden des arktischen
packeises aber dramatische folgen weit
über die arktis hinaus wenn das aktuell
für mehr als verschwindet dann nimmt der
dunkle ozean viel mehr energie von der
sonne auf als das eis was ja ein großes
größten teil dieser energie leicht
wieder zurück freut das ist eine weiße
oberfläche wird durch eine dunkle
ersetzt dadurch erwärmt sich die arktis
noch mehr und das kann auch zum instabil
werden von grönland beitragen wir haben
regen gesehen in grönland das sind
extrem seltene wetterphänomene die jetzt
aber eben auch zunehmend auch in grüner
stadt in regen in grüner
[Musik]
regen auf dem grönländischen eisschild
wissenschaftler rechnen damit dass es
hier schon bald mehr regnen und schneien
könnte mit dramatischen folgen für die
ganze welt
das gründer der preis fällt ist immens
wichtig für das klimasystem das lagern
dort gewaltige süß wassermengen die im
gegensatz zum meereis der arktis ist ja
nicht auf dem ozean schwimmen sie liegen
auf land auf und das ist ganz wichtig
denn wenn dieses eis schmilzt dann
steigt der meeresspiegel und in gröden
anstieg durch fleiß dass das für einen
meeresspiegelanstieg global von fünf bis
sieben metern reicht das müssen sie sich
mal vorstellen
das es jemals so weit kommt dass dieser
mächtige bis zu drei kilometer dicke
eispanzer vollständig abschmilzt kann
man sich kaum vorstellen wenn man
stundenlang über ihn hinweg fliegt
[Musik]
dann wird es plötzlich blau
vor uns liegt der score ist und das
größte fjord system der welt auf einer
fläche so groß wie nordrhein-westfalen
auf der anderen seite der mündung liegt
die talk to me eine kleine inuit
gemeinde die nächsten nachbarn leben auf
island etwa 700 kilometer über den
aktiven ozean
noch sind sie ihr verschont von den
großen politischen konflikten aber sie
spüren die veränderung die allem
zugrunde liegt
die kurze schotterpiste liegt am ende
eines seitenarms des fjords 70 kilometer
entfernt von der kleinen sieht
den flughafen hatte eine amerikanische
öl firma in den 80er jahren gebaut nach
fünf jahren aber wieder aufgegeben heute
ist er die einzige verbindung zur
außenwelt
mit dem gepäckwagen geht es runter an
den strand der nachmieter korte mir geht
es nur mit dem boot straßen gibt es hier
nicht
am wasser waten orgel und sein sohn
brian auf uns begrüßung warm und
herzlich so oft kommt besuch nicht
vorbei
gallo sein schwager seien mit der
cousine noch auf der anderen seite bei
der jagd sagt orgel aber er käme gleich
und dann kommen sie auch schon ackerloh
nolan mit ihrer beute für den tag
400 ackerloh geschossen und wir sind
schon ganz gespannt was es zum
abendessen gibt
schön dich wiederzusehen
2009 10 waren wir schon einmal hier ein
gefrorenes eis im juli mit mette und
orgel basel eisen ihren kindern und akku
mit des bruders
fast einen ganzen tag mussten wir unser
boot über das packeis ziel von scholle
zu scholle und zwischen ihnen hindurch
immer mit der angst einzubrechen oder
abzurutschen ein abenteuer auf das wir
nicht vorbereitet waren mitten im sommer
[Musik]
jetzt knapp drei jahre später sind wir
wieder gekommen im oktober wollen
erfahren was ich für die base lions in
den letzten beiden jahren verändert hat
wie in die tat um im service und
eineinhalb stunden dauert die fahrt in
die siedlungen einem kühlen spätherbst
tag wir müssen uns beeilen mittlerweile
wird es früh dunkel
auge und seine frau mette laden uns zum
abendessen mit den kindern ein es gebe
etwas ganz besonderes für uns
moschusochsen bürger alles selbst
gemacht aus dem ersten moschusochsen den
bringen der jüngste gerade geschossen
habe
kannst du dich noch erinnern letztes mal
das ganze eis ja genau aber dieses jahr
hatten wir gar kein eis den ganzen
sommer nicht überhaupt keins nichts nur
eisberg
am nächsten morgen erste mal noch eine
extra lange klamotten jetzt wehren uns
mit unseren dicken jacken in einen
isolierten anzug der vor wind und wasser
schützen soll und vor kate - 15 20 grad
kann es um diese jahreszeit werden als
wir aufbrechen sind es etwa minus 10 wir
fahren in dem offenen boot mit all-in
und kakadus wollen dass eltern
verabschieden uns dirk und brian einer
unserer beiden kameramänner fahren mit
org
lange strecken weit hinein in den fjord
oder in den ozean hinaus geht es immer
nur mit zwei booten zur sicherheit
wir brechen auf zu einem experiment
wollen zu einem ort der noch nie ein
inuit im oktober erreicht hat zu tief
liegt er im fjord zunahm eispanzer
250 kilometer luftlinie von tokio
entfernt
[Musik]
mehrere tage werden wir unterwegs seien
durch den fjord
und es wird stunden geben in denen wir
bereuen überhaupt gekommen zu sein
noch aber können wir uns all das nicht
vorstellen an diesem kalten aber
friedlichen spät oktobertag
[Musik]